I know you're scared but I'm here to
protect you
she's gonna need all of us NATO dog face
film is not yet rated you have no idea
what we're up against how do I stop this
it will take all of us we choose our
weapons and we take it down
native dog fate this film is not yet
rated
[Music]
my name is Sarah Connor I hunt
terminators he's the most lethal
Terminator ever created Sarah Connor I'm
going to help you we choose our weapons
and we take it down
terminated or fade I'll be back a
[Music]
machine from the future once you're dead
we need to be ready
[Music]
it's a most beautiful Terminator ever
created we don't win this one it's all
over
it's my mission to protect her
you don't know what we're up against
[Music]
we don't win this one
so I'm going to help you change the
future
I'll be back will he start to kill me
here run we gotta move
juice cut it up [ __ ] out
if we don't win this one
she party night cool
through your body
totally typography to when we're done I
am going to kill you
she was a big stickable
you